ladies and gentlemen indeed we all
condemn the massacre um by Hamas on the
7th of October we all call for the
release of hostages and we all have to
protect and save civilians in Gaza we
have to protect lives and preserve
Humanity as you said rightly so and in
this context let me present what our
contribution is so far and where we want
to work more intensively with you the
European Commission knows Gaza very well
for decades together with the member
states we've been working with the
people in Gaza we have been one of the
largest donor to the Palestinian people
um this includes of course
unra commiss General so these very close
ties that we have established to the
people of Gaza pay off of course today
because this increases the possibility
to coordinate and uh to answer to the
needs we have started as European
commission to immediately work on these
humanitarian assistant to the people of
Gaza we have tripled our humanitarian
Aid and in the runup of this conference
we have quadrupled the humanitarian
support for Gaza and the West Bank but
it's mostly for Gaza up to 100 million
euros and we have launched logistical
support to Egypt um Egypt has designated
Al arish airport uh in the north of
Sinai um as a logistical Hub so here
we're also working to support uh and
increase the logistic capabilities of
this Hub indeed um Mr President as you
said we have launched a humanitarian
airbridge so far eight flights have been
uh completed carrying more than 370 tons
of medicines water and sanitary items
and we are preparing preparing flights
on almost a daily basis we have made a
good experience by establishing a
coordination cell with the International
Federation of Red Cross and red
crescent um and we think uh and that's
what we're doing that donations should
be channeled through this platform to
have an Optimum of
coordination in parallel we are also
reinforcing the local logistical
capacity of the Egyptian red crescent
for for instant with refrigerated mobile
storage also by sending our logistic
Personnel on the
ground most of our cargos have already
reached Gaza by truck through the
rougher border crossing but as almost
everyone said here the volumes remain
too small to match the massive
humanitarian needs so while we fully
support to increase the capacity um of
Aid delivered through Raa Rafa and this
is our first priority priority we also
need to look urgently as additional
routs so it was called more than one
entry point and this is why we very much
welcome and work very closely with
President Nikos christes from Cyprus to
establish a maritime Corridor I think
this would guarantee a sustained a
regulated and a robust flow of Aid um
and uh Mr President you will certainly
detail so I don't have to uh prolong my
comments here but full support from the
European commission with all the
logistics and the possibilities that we
have we will of course continue to help
evacuate injured Palestinians who
received medical assistance in Egypt
this includes also providing medicines
and medical equipment to
Egypt this humanitarian effort goes hand
in hand with the work to a avoid a
spillover in the region um and therefore
we are also working to give strong
support to the region on Tuesday I
discussed with king king abdalah of
Jordan during his visit to
Brussels um a New Economic and financial
package uh to further strengthen Jordan
and I discussed with President D CI also
how Europe can work and strengthen
intensify the partnership that we have
with Egypt a whole comprehensive package
here this is for the immediate but also
the mid and the long term to stabilize
the region and to stabilize the most
important actors in the region um also
finally Mr President on your third
pillar we also think that as we have to
deal with the urgency of today we must
make the effort to think about tomorrow
um how to break the current spiral of
violence and how hope can be reestablish
between Israelis and Palestinians for
that they need a political perspective
and this perspective is the two-state
solution and to work here intensively on
this one of course it's Israelis and P
Palestinians who will in the very end
have to agree on a way forward but we as
a part of an international effort must
also contribute in very close
coordination with our friends and
partners thank you very much Mr
President